well Joe Biden is in Poland doing his
semi-literate Winston Churchill
imitation his own country doesn't seem
to be improving thousands of Americans
in East Palestine Ohio for example are
worried about their health and their
finances Fox's Garrett Tenney just spoke
to one of them
half a mile down the tracks from where a
Norfolk Southern Train derailed Chris
rimoldi says like a lot of people in
this town he's stuck I do Roofing and
signing for a living are you going to
want to put sodding and a new roof on
your house that your property values are
dropping so my future's uncertain as far
as my business in this town Chris also
isn't convinced the air inside his home
is safe despite testing by the railway
last week his family's health issues
haven't gone away and yesterday he says
his fiance found an oily sheen on top of
their dehumidifiers water so that tells
me that if this chemical sticks to water
my dehumidifiers taking water out of the
air in the basement
it's obviously still there
so as all this is going on the
transportation secretary is supposed to
be preventing train derailments hasn't
bothered to visit East Palestine Ohio
more than two weeks after the derailment
more than two weeks after authorities
lit the toxic chemicals on fire this
doesn't have time but he does have time
to do morning shows he just did
when are you going to go to East
Palestine
well I am planning to go when I go the
focus is going to be on action look I
was mayor of my hometown for eight years
we dealt with a lot of disasters natural
and human and one of the things I
noticed very quickly is that there's two
kinds of people who show up when you
have that kind of disaster experience
people who are there because they have a
specific job to do and are there to get
something done and people who are there
to look good and have their picture
taken when I go it will be about action
on rail safety
if there's any member of the bite
Administration who deserves to lose his
job immediately it's that guy Nathan and
Kelly exotic are in East Palestine they
live there we talked to them a couple
days ago and since we spoke they tell us
they've been coughing up blood so we
want to get an update from Nathan and
Kelly join us now thank you both for
coming on
um Nathan first you coughing up blood
yes Tucker um it was days after the
incident and um that's it would have
been the Sunday and I woke up in a very
horrific coughing spell almost like a
bronchitis or pneumonia type and uh yeah
I don't know if it was just from the the
coughing fits or what but spots of blood
that appear that night and uh a few days
later obviously we evacuated Town it
resided and went away but that was one
of the side effects how how old are you
I am I'm 30 now just turned 30 in
February 16th yeah I'm no doctor but you
should not be coughing up blood and
we're going to speak to a doctor in a
minute I mean I'm telling you what you
know
um but that's not a good sign Kelly how
are you feeling
the headaches are horrible
um they pretty much when I'm about three
to four miles outside of town
um they start and as long as I'm within
a few miles of uh the the crash site
I've got headaches really bad headaches
migraines
has anyone tried to explain to you why
you might be having these symptoms
well if we're talking the Ohio Dr
fauci's we can go and you know they're
going to try to point it towards
having coveted related symptoms but we
obviously know that's not the case yeah
no that's not the kid coughing up blood
is not is not I don't think a valid
coveted symptom at this point how does
it smell I mean we have a sense of smell
for a reason the nose knows that you
know there's truth in that how does your
Town smell
I mean it's it's still blatant uh even
uh your cameraman here that's one of the
first things I asked him was you know do
you smell what's smelling outside and he
says yeah it's it's it's a sweet odor um
it it smells terrible and again it's
it's more time towards the evening when
it's more prominent
yeah I I hate to ask you about money but
I can't resist I mean what about
homeowners in East Palestine like you've
got to think that their home values are
bottoming out
go ahead nobody is ever going to
purchase a home that has these Palestine
in the in the address I mean this is
this has definitely made our value
plummet
are you are you homeowners
yes we we are homeless here sir
man I'm so sorry the future isn't yeah
the future isn't right
yeah your health and your wealth in May
oh
yeah
I'm sorry I'm really sorry um but we
appreciate the update from both of you
tonight Nathan and Kelly exotic thanks
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight